vivek's been pushing this message that
it's like the administrative class and
everybody it's not Republican and
Democrat it's there's an administrative
class that's hijacked this country and
then there's everybody else and I think
along with what Tim said big agriculture
big Pharma big Tech I mean these things
are the single I mean it's not a single
yeah big act that's the worst like dude
something is wrong with the food in this
country and everybody I asked who's
traveled abroad says the same thing you
eat the exact same food in Mexico you
lose weight like crazy you eat the same
food in America you gain weight like
crazy something's wrong something is
wrong it's like when it's like when you
feed a duck a bunch of bread yeah when
it just inflates and then dies and stuff
with like potassium it's like and crap
like that maybe that's it I don't know